[Musique]
bonjour à tous mon coup de coeur cinéma
du jour c'est le film saw réalisé par
James one sortie en 2004 alors
l'histoire de sous c'est très simple
c'est deux personnages dont tu ne
connais rien qui se réveille dans une
espèce de salle de bain désaffectée ils
sont tous les deux enchaînés il ne se
connaissent pas et pourtant ils vont
devoir sortir de là
je veux jouer à un jeu
ce film est un film d'horreur un des
premiers de son réalisateur James one
qui a quand même réalisé ce conjuring et
insidious donc on peut dire que c'est un
petit peu l'un des boss de films
d'horreur actuels et ce film en fait est
le nouveau d'un genre il a pris un film
qui s'appelle cube et il a pris un film
qui s'appelle seven de David Fincher que
vous connaissez peut-être il a mélangé
les deux et il a popularisé ce qu'on
appelle le torture porn c'est-à-dire
voilà des films un petit peu gore un
petit peu d'horreur tout en ayant
vraiment cet aspect énigmatique parce
que pour sortir c'est de personnes là
vont se rendre compte qui se connaissent
un petit peu j'en ai assez de ces gens
qui n'apprécient pas leur chance de
vivre je donne un but à votre vie il
répondent aux ordres d'un fameux zikxo
qu'ils entendent grâce à des cassettes
qu'ils ont un petit peu éparpillé
partout si vous aimez les escape game
les puzzles et les films d'horreur très
clairement sauf c'est pour vous
[Musique]